[Musique]
pour tous ces étudiants le bac encore le
brevet des collèges s'est gagné la
Bibliothèque départementale a fait
honneur au diplômé et plus
particulièrement au bachelier depuis
maintenant 3 ans la BDR change ses
horaires d'ouverture et de fermeture
pour permettre au lycéen de terminal de
réviser plus longtemps des annales sont
également mis à leur disposition je
tiens éalement ficiter tous les jeunes
qui ont eu leur examen c'est la 3e année
qu'on met en place ce dispositif pour
aider les étudiants à réussir davantage
euh d'ailleurs il y a eu plus de 3500
étudiants sur 20 jours on met des livres
à leur disposition et puis on les
accueille on les encourage des révisions
plus tardives des révisions en groupe ou
seul à chacun sa formule une formule
payante puisque 100 % des étudiants qui
sont venus à la bibliothèque cette année
ont réussi leur baccalauréat à l'image
de Rachelle et Yasmine qui ont trouvé le
cadre idéal pour décrocher le précieux
ses âes ça nous a permis de nous
retrouver en groupe et d'échanger nos
connaissances avec ceux qui arrivent pas
forcément et puis voilà de s'entraider
surt ça vous vous avez passé combien de
temps ici au moins de semaines à peu
près ou Coralie étudiante du Sud a
trouvé son inspiration dans les ouvrages
de la bibliothèque départementale
c'était mes révisions en même temps les
ouvrages et en même temps les
expositions qui étaient présentées ici
qui m'ont attiré et franchement c'est un
endroit agréable reposant et pour
réviser votre bac c'est un endroit
parfait je trouve très calme personne
vous dérange et tout le monde est
accueillant ici des bacheliers heureux
et des parents tout aussi impressionnés
par les résultats de leurs enfants
Rachel fait la fierté de ses parents
content de déjà du résultat et aussi
que le Conseil général participe à tout
ça pour motiver un peu les jeunes et
guider un peu après peut-être par la
suite près normal N sont très très F
d'elle une cérémonie qui a été aussi
l'occasion de proposer aux futurs
étudiants les dispositif d'aide mise en
place par le Conseil départemental sur
le site netbour c'est donc les
étudiants s'inscrivent donc nous donne
un certain nombre d'information ils vont
confirmer leur projet à la rentrée
universitaire par l'envoie d'un certain
nombre de pièces donc notamment le
certificat de scolarité et nous allons
déclencher dans la par la suite donc les
différents paiements que ce soit la
Bourse ou la location de scol
un cocktail et un cadeau pour
récompenser l'assiduité de ces étudiants
qui garderont un souvenir précis de leur
bac et de la manière dont ils ont pu
obtenir leur diplôme le passio de la
Bibliothèque départementale y est
sûrement pour quelque
[Musique]
chose